sino que muchas veces piensan que cuando
se tiene una discapacidad no se puede
trabajar no se pueden ser independiente
tienes que estar ahí viendo ya haciendo
lo que tus padres que tengan que ver en
que llevar que lo puedes tener nada
propio de una casa o carro un trabajo
una medida la gente pudiera pensar eso
y yo creo que son las que tienen
discapacidad tampoco es así yo tengo la
discapacidad de esta crisis y perfecta
es una perversidad como vasos de cristal
normalmente cuando uno nace con esta
discapacidad de fracturas constantemente
con pequeños movimientos pequeñitos
golpes que cualquier libio en su le pasa
eso lo que sucede es que se hace un
raspón conmigo no era una fractura
cada vez que yo me pegaba en alguna
parte del cuerpo y entonces pasó tiempo
y artillarlas y con diez fracturas y se
dedicó saturando en el largo del
incidente vivida recientemente pude
estudiar como cualquier persona en un
convencional y entonces yo quería
independizarse y yo quería ser
como cualquiera de salinas poder volver
a donde yo fuera yo quisiera y para eso
saber lo que tenemos que estudiar y
estar preparadas estudio en el carácter
internacional de grado 1 y pienso que
como cualquier persona voy a poder tener
trabajo y la verdad es que no
batallé mucho toque muchas puertas en
aquel entonces las empresas no estaban
tan abiertas para contratar a una
persona con discapacidad pero sí porque
siempre hay un en la empresa o la
persona que salva la vida de alguien que
tiene algún problema entonces empiezo yo
a empresas más pequeñas siempre por una
meta y con el sueño de querer trabajar
en una empresa grande o en un
corporativo
para que sienta si quieren mayores
posibilidades negras oportunidades
aprendes más te traigo verde área más
fácilmente y entonces después de tratar
varias cuentas cuentas puede estar en
diferentes empresas -aquellas logró
entrar hacer esa la verdad es que ha
sido una decisión para y fue el que yo
había soñado y estar en una empresa como
lo es con oxxo cocacola cervecería para
mí porque hasta ahorita es profundo que
lo que yo podría se está logrando
estudié seis años y medio pero yo quería
más yo soy de las personas que le
conformó por cualquier cosita
ya no sé yo quería darle armas ahí ya no
iba a poder yo quería desenvolverme y de
sentirme en otro tipo de trabajo porque
como cualquiera de ustedes
puedes empezar con un trabajo previendo
pero por la base nando puedes subir y
subir ser coordinador es entonces cuando
veo que ya no se podía y lo supone por
la discapacidad mujeres creo que es un
momento de cambiar y de moverme a otra
empresa porque la discapacidad pues sé
si va a estar o sea cuando te dice el
cambio de área porque necesitas estar
una estrella o porque necesitas irte a
vivir a otro país
pero cuando lo tengo en el área más por
tu discapacidad
entonces el que yo buscaba en donde sí
donde si hay una empresa que quiera
querían personas con discapacidad pero
no había ese crecimiento entonces
la oportunidad le abren las puertas en
el sigma alimentos
con lo cual le endureció porque justo en
el área responsabilidad social para que
yo pudiera ellos contratar a gente con
discapacidad pero no había un programa
como tal no estaba la estructura no
había un valor entonces tú haz lo que
quieras o crea el programa de inclusión
laboral 11 verso y poder equipar y hacer
y yo que cuando yo estuve en pared
exprés acción hicieron no les dieron o
me gustó de ciertas empresas y agarré
tips fue lo mejor cree el programa
tenemos talento porque el ciclo de
importantes el talento del ejerce y se
hizo un programa anual de discusión
entonces llegué a ese ambiente estaba
aprendiendo mucho está cuando practican
mis conocimientos y propia como
discapacidad era un poco más fácil
desarrollar ese puesto además de
empresarias y otras cosas que tenía él
en área de responsabilidad social y
nuevo
[Música]
pasan los años
8 ya están que necesito más necesito
perder más necesito crecer porque ya con
lo que estaba por hacer de los ojos y
hacerlo no me gusta que darle esta
entrada entonces me cambien el área
de procesos de tecnología de informática
al principio que el que ese colegio dije
que dije no sabían lo que estaba
pidiendo no entendía nada
mucha tecnología muchos procesos
yo no soy bueno no era tiene procesos se
debe hacer y puede ser arriba y hacia
abajo y aquí no se es paso a paso dos o
tres estos 80 y yo es un diente no daba
rigor y como legal pero que lo dominó
después de empresarios y le dio y
gracias a ese movimiento ya ese
aprendizaje este el agente insigne le
empieza a conocer más loco no los
conociera porque la carrera es
personalidad sociales y hay muchas cosas
que involucraban a la gente porque
éramos cosas del capital humano pero
empiezas en procesos estoy justo en los
procesos
marketing y finanzas entonces
aprendiendo demasiado conociendo como
ustedes lunario globales en el área
central entonces no nada más cabo
procesos para signo méxico ha sido
paradigma mundial entonces dependiendo
del área que nos pide el proyecto pues
se implementa en costa rica en varias
partes de europa en eeuu 10 ahí 2000 yo
digo realmente ya le siento totalmente
realizada bien siento que soy como
cualquier persona y cualquiera
discapacidad que hacemos siempre grande
y si ustedes encuentran a una persona
con discapacidad que cree que no puede
hacer algo o que esté a expensas de su
casa o de alguien que no sea realmente
una silla de ruedas un bastón o
cualquier aditamento que se necesita
para poder desempeñarse laboralmente se
puede se puede elegir el pp sé que hay
este varias personas con discapacidades
marian que es una de ellas que me hacía
de ruedas y entonces no tenemos a pesar
de tener discapacidad podemos ser los
más independientes que se fuera por
tanto ahora traigo la idea desde hace 23
años de que le pudiera vivir a españa
necesito mis papás casi dos antenas así
necesitas de nosotros entonces pues el
móvil
y en qué va a pasar necesito mis copas
no son super valiosos a lo largo del
vídeo el regulador impresionantemente
tengo llegamos sólo si no vamos solos
entonces
con el trabajo tener siempre presente la
verdad y estar de guardia de estar en
las relaciones públicas son muy
importantes y importan si es que por ser
diferente no puede ser caliente no
importan las diferencias no importa
porque yo pudiera pensar este es con 28
perrito y como soy gordita estos donde
voy a poder ser modelo y el flojo
entonces la apariencia física lo impide
nada para este trabajo lo impide para
que te desarrollos y vive para que seas
independiente
yo veo casos de alumnos sus compañeros
que están bien le mans a su casa y
apenas ha empezado a trabajar
porque no puedes como traigo yo
entonces
[Música]
cualquier día con la silla le puedo
mover me puedo bajar y subir sola pero
esto no es impedimento para ser
independiente
para el trabajo en empresa de mis sueños
y para poder lograr cada una de mis
metas y espero que la que sigo pudiera
ser la de globe y ver a españa porque y
cía en mucho más indiferencia
ahí sí
obviamente sería más esfuerzo físico de
mi parte pero no puedo mover para todos
lados y subir y bajar l
a diferencia de aquí pero lo único que
necesito es
no dependo de nadie somos totalmente de
lo más
minutos está entendiendo el des pero
siempre aprenden cosas nuevas
relaciones de gente
no tienes que ser importante sino
interesante y bueno frutas se cierran
las puertas y pretenden ir a cualquier
evento formación digital que ustedes
creen que es la verdad es que muchos
lados con sus contactos que van a abrir
las puertas para tus sueños por
cualquier lado imaginar de dónde va a
ser pero esos contactos te van a abrir
las puertas que van en el trabajo
siempre se tienen que sentir utilizar el
trabajo no trabajen por trabajar o
porque te van a pagar
felipe sus trabajo en lenguaje te gusta
que la ducati siempre realizada y cara
que el diferente en el coral deficiente
súper realizada al estar metiendo el
queso rallado en las bolsas ya tampoco
tiene que ser una realización del para
tan extremo es diferente el trabajo
importante
hay una capacidad de que otros a eso no
importa la cosa es que tú seas tu dieta
que tú seas tú todo para que tú seas que
quiera alcanzar algo y le remera y poner
y yo les puedo decir es que aunque
tengas una discapacidad eso no impide a
ser totalmente dependiente a poder tener
unas casas que tú puedas vivir sola para
poder tener el trabajo o el negocio de
tus sueños
por ejemplo en mi caso el libro que más
tiempo
el autor ha metido
la psicología dentro del libro es
impactante poder decir nada más un libro
está en méxico sobre todo en el españa
tenemos como cuatro presentaciones y son
sueños y en el mejor
es tan hacer algo extra aparte del
trabajo del siglo
los límites
trabajo mucho me siento más
independientes a hoy en las parejas
eso sí porque lo uso veces pasa que los
años porque tú lo que te dice que no
trabaja acerca de dónde está el no pues
son 106 no dependemos de nadie seamos
autosuficientes en el cuerpo que tengan
discapacidades tú puedes hacer y
deshacer y aprender y trabajar en lo que
tú quieras siempre y cuando tú te lo
propongas y lo logres y luchas con ellos